but i aspire to do far more than that
and devise something of real power
what is it you hope to craft
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
will be my full lord of the rings the
rings of power episode 1 and episode 2
video there were a whole bunch of easter
eggs and references and i'll explain
what's going on with the timeline during
these events in the show because there's
a bunch of stuff that they speed run
over but as the name imply the rings of
power the series is all about during the
second age when sauron created the
actual rings of power and the one ring
of power one ring to rule them all
so be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes there's going to be eight
episodes total during season one and i
believe part of the deal that amazon had
to sign to get the rights to actually do
this show required them to do like up to
five seasons so i'm pretty sure that
unless something really weird goes on
they will definitely do season two they
spent about a half a billion dollars
just to get season one out the door but
they had to spend about half of that
money just to get the rights so really
they only spent about 250 million
dollars on season one but careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet we'll just start at the
beginning and work our way through scene
by scene talking about easter eggs wtf
moments and like the really important
stuff the title of episode 1 is called a
shadow of the past it's a reference to a
bunch of different things mostly morgoth
and sauron in the war of wrath in the
present day of the show it's a couple
years after the war of wrath has ended
sauron becomes the quote-unquote shadow
that they mention a couple times through
the first two episodes the metaphorical
and the literal shadow from the past war
threatening to gain strength and start a
new war like the war of the ring the war
of the last alliance like i said the
present day of the show is mostly during
the second age the second age only
lasted for like a little over 3 400
years everything before that like the
first stage the year of the trees the
pre-history that's closer to like 20 000
years so when i say they speed run
through like the first 20 000 years of
history or so yeah they really did
speedrun i think that's for a couple
different reasons one because they're
just using it as a prologue meant to be
a mirror for the prologue and fellowship
of the ring like even though they
obviously have a new version of
galadriel playing the character it's
also galadriel doing the narration of
the prologue just like she did during
fellowship of the ring in the prologue
itself is very similar to the prologue
to fellowship of the ring like it covers
the last major war like the last major
conflict in what happens right after
that the war they cover in fellowship
with the ring in the prologue is the war
of the last alliance the third age
begins like right after sauron is
defeated at the beginning of this show
the first stage ends right after morgoth
is defeated so when we're meeting the
little girl version of galadriel here
she's less than 100 years old she was
about 138 years old when the two trees
were destroyed when she says nothing is
evil in the beginning that's a reference
to morgoth himself because he wasn't
created by a louvitar as an evil being
the cosmic hierarchy of power within the
lord of the rings universe works like
this so up at the top you have the one
true god of the universe that's a
louvitar beneath him are the valar those
are like the lesser gods but they're
still gods morgoth was the most powerful
of all those gods beneath their pantheon
or the lesser powerful may are they're
more like angels still super powerful
cosmic beings but not nearly as powerful
as the valar sauron and gandalf for
instance are both part of the mayar but
they're part of different sub-branches
of those groups of angels when you see
the characters walking around on
middle-earth throughout the events of
the movies obviously the tv show now
they're basically like cosmic beings
trapped in human form it's sort of like
the star wars reference like when you
become a force ghost you become way more
powerful they're way more powerful in
their true cosmic forms so like when
sauron and gandalf are walking around on
middle earth they're like special cosmic
rules that prevent them from using their
full power so what you see them using
during the movies is like a fraction of
their true power and what galadriel is
narrating here is basically morgoth
turning evil because of his pride and
eventually seeking to rule over the
world and that leading to the
destruction of the trees the war of the
wrath or the war of the jewels as they
call it because it's the war of the
silmarils a lot of that is covered
during the events of the silmarillion
the main events of this series during
the second age is more about what sauron
does after all that trying his own more
subversive plan for taking over the
world using the rings of power they kind
of brush over this during galadriel's
prologue here but sauron starts out as
sort of like the chief lieutenant of one
of the other greater gods serving
morgoth so sauron started out being like
the underling's underling in a cosmic
sense like he wasn't even that close to
morgoth even though during the events of
the movies they make him seem like this
really crazy cosmic big bad morgoth his
ultimate master was way way more
powerful but when galadriel says there
hadn't been a sunrise yet that's
actually meant to be taken literally
because originally all the light on the
continent here like when you see her
running around in the field with their
friends here and there's light shining
down on them that's not coming from the
sun the light is coming from the two
trees those trees provided light for the
entire continent of valinor here it
wasn't until morgoth and his servant the
great spider angolian the ancestor of
shella the giant spider destroyed the
trees and then the remnants of the trees
became the moon and the sun and then you
have the first actual sunrise so just to
give you an idea for how old galadriel
is during the events of the lord of the
rings movies she's over 8 000 years old
when the events of this series pick up
in present day she's closer to like a
thousand years old in the actual first
episode when they pick up in the waste
with them on their mission is a couple
hundred years after the start of the
second age really cool side detail too
when you see the two trees being
destroyed by morgoth you see his shadow
rise above them they were actually able
to use some of the remnants of those
trees to seed saplings that became like
the white tree of gondor in the other
white trees that we'll see like there's
one on numenor too the whole scene of
the boat in the water is just meant to
give you an idea for what her
personality is like and this is one of
the big changes i think from the books
as most people know them so far is that
galadriel in this series is way stabbier
way more aggressive than the book
version is being portrayed then we meet
her brother finrod who she was really
close to it's his death at the hands of
sauron and morgoth's men that drives her
to find sauron during the events of the
series and try to kill him they only
show a montage of the war and his death
but he was captured by sauron's men
later and tortured in his dungeons
that's how he died it was a really
gruesome death in the episode they show
sauron's magical brand on his body i
don't recall seeing the brand in the
lord of the rings lore before this so
they might have created it for the show
but essentially it's exactly what
galadriel says it is during the episode
even though they claim that their elvin
smiths have no idea what it is nobody
can decode this i think the whole idea
here is that it's meant to be a magical
rune that serves a couple different
purposes like it looks really wicked it
just freaks people out in general
because it's magical orcs and servants
of sauron can also use it to follow his
trail he can also direct his armies and
leave secret messages for them to decode
and also i believe the mark itself
because it has a special magical brand
and it's tied to this dark altar in the
place that we see during the prologue
with all those orcs melted into the wall
using dark magic i think the whole idea
with the mark is that it becomes a
precursor to what the rings of power
will eventually become the way that
sauron binds his power to the many
lesser rings to the one ring of power
like all the rings contain a piece of
his essence which is why he's able to
control all them through the one ring
this is where we get to the special
sword the theo finds with the brand on
it that responds to his blood the mark
itself looks exactly like the mark on
the sword hilt so the early theory is
that this mark of sauron will be
something that sauron bakes into the
creation of the rings of power and is
sort of like a magical slave system that
binds everything to himself also i have
some other theories about what's going
on with the sword and with the hal brand
character because the symbol on the
necklace that hal brand is wearing is
from the same village that bronwyn is
from and how bran says that he is from
the southlands which is where bronwyn
and theo are from so the other biggest
thing on the show is the whole mystery
of who is sauron in disguise during this
part of the timeline all we know from
the books is that he disguised himself
in the form of an elf named himself
anatar and pretended to be friends to
the elves instead that he brought them
these gifts from the gods he was going
to help them and that's how he was able
to deceive keller brimbore into creating
the rings of power now keller brimbore
himself didn't create all the rings of
power himself he just created the elven
rings other people working with him
created the other rings of power but
like during episode 2 you see keller
brimbore showing elrond his plans for
the most powerful forge ever created in
middle earth the forge that they'll
eventually probably use to create the
rings of power my early theory right now
though is that they'll end season one
with the creation or beginning the
creation of the actual forge like
they're going to get help from the
dwarves and it's already the end of
episode two and the dwarves have not
completely agreed to help them create it
yet so the whole idea is that they
actually probably won't make the real
rings of power to like season three
season four like however many seasons
the show runs in all that time we'll
just be playing this guessing game who
is sauron but i do have some theories
you all probably have some theories too
after watching the first couple of
episodes you can definitely tell that
amazon has changed some of the story for
the character just so you don't
immediately recognize who sauron's going
to be but the whole reason why it was
rings that sauron used to try and take
over the world was because that was his
specialty making magical items like that
his master that he studied under that he
served was called allowed he was also
called the smith literally the god of
forging things so that's why sauron was
an expert at crafting magical items like
the rings of power and that's why he
would try to deceive keller brimbore
because he is like the greatest
craftsman of the elves the greatest
craftsman in the land the only big
surprise here during the prologue is
that you don't actually see morgoth
himself you just see his shadow above
the two trees here i'll talk a little
bit more about the oath of feyenoord
when i talk about elrond when he shows
up later in the episode but the whole
idea is that the war of wrath was
literally called the war of the jewels
because it was a war over the silmarils
themselves they were actually crafted by
feanor to contain some of the essence of
the two trees that morgoth destroyed so
they just had this incredible amount of
cosmic power that he used to enhance his
own power we see all the elven ships
sailing to war this is them leaving the
continent of valinor and going to
middle-earth as the map shows i do love
the way they do transitions in this with
the map this is happening on this part
of the continent belaria where the elves
lived after they came to middle earth
and you have to keep in mind that this
is a crazy speed run version of the plot
because hundreds of years have gone by
between the time that they sailed and
when this actual battle is happening
when her brother is getting ready to
fall but what happened here is that the
other gods themselves got involved in
the war and there was so much power
running around in this part of middle
earth that the collateral damage from
all their battles literally sank the
part of the continent underneath the
ocean which is also a bit foreshadowing
for numenor a big part of the series
will be covering the downfall of numenor
but we really won't see a lot of numenor
stuff till episode 3 it seems like
the only bummer here is that they don't
actually show you what they did to
morgoth after they defeated him because
he was literally like the most powerful
god next to the one true god a louvitar
they couldn't actually kill him the only
way that they could stop him was to
permanently trap him in this void-like
abyss outside of creation
so like all the way during the events of
the movies later in the timeline during
the fourth age there's all these
prophecies about his eventual return
like darkness will return because he's
still alive he's just kind of chilling
out there in the middle of nothingness
but the final act that they show you in
the prologue is the younger sauron on
screen in his familiar suit of armor
that you see him fighting in during the
war the last alliance and if you
couldn't tell this area where they show
him is the same place in the frozen
north that galadriel's squad visits
later in the episode hundreds and
hundreds of years later galadriel
explains how her brother was captured
and tortured by him and that's why they
try to make it so personal for her his
dagger that she carries with her for all
these hundreds of years will be
important again in a second when i start
talking about hal brand too more clues
and easter eggs on our path to finding
out who the secret sauron is on the show
is sort of like game of thrones and
finding out who the secret targaryens
are when her voice over kind of fades
out and they step into the present day
of the show then climbing up the cliff
face here a lot of her dialogue sounds
very similar to the dialogue during the
fellowship of the ring prologue when
she's talking about how people just over
time because of their short life spans
just forgot about the war the last
alliance in the ring of power until
smeagol found it in the river
more and more of our kind
began to believe that sauron
was but a memory
and some things that should not have
been forgotten
were lost
so it's the same idea at the beginning
of the main events of this series where
like most people just don't have the
long life spans that elves have and have
forgotten about the war of wrath morgoth
and sauron in general so that i really
worried about him
much to their misfortune when they find
the altar with sauron's magical sigil on
it the orc fused to the wall like i said
galadriel says some dark magic was being
worked here by sauron the magic was
probably him working on a spell to
change his appearance disguised himself
it's also probably connected to the
special sword that theo finds in the
southlands where hal bran says he came
from and if it was hidden in his house
maybe he is secretly hal bran's son
because theo says he has no idea what
happened to his father even though his
mother is in love with the elf iran deer
there's a lot of theories i have now
about what's going on with theo mystery
dad not sure who he is finds what looks
like sauron sword with his special sigil
on it that activates when it tastes some
blood a lot of theories about whether or
not sauron could ever potentially have
any illegitimate children there aren't
any children of his in the books that
they ever speak of but it is possible
for mayor to have children with mortals
and other people on earth because one of
the parents of luthien of the famous
baron and luthien one of elron's
ancestors was a mayar but like i said i
think the whole idea with the sigil is
that it's sort of like a precursor to
what he'll bake into the rings of power
sort of like a horcrux type of magical
sigil
when she says that they were meddling
with the powers of the unseen world
that's the wraith world that you see
when frodo and bilbo put the ring of
power on it's like a pure magical realm
they have the snowtrow battle just
showing you some of galadriel's skills
with weapons she'll have more fight
scenes in future episodes some of them
more playful than others her officers
betray her wanting to go back to linden
putting down their swords and you get a
big swell up of this really cool music
score all the music for the series is
being done by bear mccreary who most of
you will probably remember from
battlestar galactica or something else
recently he's done a bunch of really
cool stuff then they reveal the har
foots and they're meant to be kind of
like the show's version of hobbits so
hard foots are not characters from the
books like they invented them for the tv
show because the first hobbits didn't
appear on middle earth until the third
age the main character here sort of like
the frodo of the series is meant to be
nori she's the one that eventually finds
the meteor man lots of early theories
about what's going on with him he looks
very much kind of like gandalf but
gandalf didn't come to middle earth
until the third age so obviously he's
probably some other type of wizard maybe
one of the blue wizards and when he's
trying to tell nori who he is where he
comes from he uses his magic to create
the image of one of the constellations
in the sky whispering to fireflies like
gandalf whispered to birds he was
speaking quenya the language of the
elves and i think he was trying to tell
her that he literally fell from the
heavens like he crashed down from the
heavens like pointing up at the
constellations and was sent to middle
earth to help everyone the same way that
gandalf was eventually sent to earth it
also seems like he's full of magical
power like the fire responds to him when
he sits up and then sits back down the
only thing i think is a misdirect here
though because everyone's kind of
wondering who is sauron going to be who
is meteor man going to be when they zoom
out on the picture of his crash site it
looks kind of like the flaming eye of
sauron i think that's meant to be a
misdirect like meteor man is not meant
to be sauron then we see elrond for the
first time the actor you may recognize
he's the same person who played young
ned stark on game of thrones during the
events of this series at this point in
the timeline elrond is more of a
diplomat within their hierarchy in
linden which is why he's the one to go
treat with the doors because he's got
this pre-existing relationship that goes
back to the war of wrath there are a
bunch of different groups of elves
around middle earth and just around the
world in general so the high elves are
the noldor here that gil galad rules
over so just because he is the high king
of the noldor doesn't mean that he rules
over every single elf so for example
iran deer comes from the cindar elves
that's the group of elves that legolas
and his father come from like his father
has been their king for a long long time
they descend from a completely different
line than galadriel and the noldor
descend from so for example gil gallad
and keller brimbour are both galadriel's
cousins and for example their
grandfather fenway was actually the
ruler of this city here where the two
trees are that you see during the
prologue it's called tyrion it still
exists there but it's on a completely
different continent you have to remember
galadriel basically came to middle earth
during the start of the first stage and
for example elrond wasn't born till
later till after all the elves had come
to middle earth in beleriad here so he
has never been to valinor until the end
of return of the king when they all
depart the grey havens to go back to the
undying lands which is on valinor
there's a quick scene with the harfoots
where nori's mother references following
the trail i think because they're meant
to be the ancestors of the hobbits
that's meant to be a reference to the
actual hobbit story because in that
story there's this whole tale about
bilbo and the dwarves leaving the path
in merkwood which is where they run into
the spiders and things go off the rails
we see gilgalad give galadriel soldiers
the honor of going back to valinor which
she obviously bails on at the end of the
episode and when elrond tells her her
chance to go there might not come again
that's obviously a reference to the end
of return of the king when she goes
there again you also have to remember
during this conversation when they're
looking at the mural here that is
literally like the passage that you see
them undertaking at the end of the
episode elrond is treating it like such
a huge deal because he's never been
there he's only heard about this place
then we meet the southlanders so
southlanders are just what they called
regular humans who lived in middle earth
this whole time and were not numenoreans
like regular people without special
god-given longer lifespans like the
numenoreans they set up this very barren
and luthien aragorn and arwen type of
relationship story with iran deer in
bronwyn what's been going on in this
area of the world since the war of wrath
had ended is that the elves just in
general like all elves all groups of
elves have been watching over the
southlanders race to make sure that they
don't do anything bad again because
during the war of wrath they're race
sided with morgoth like i said the iran
deer himself and his group of elves in
the tower here are from the sylvan elves
which is the same group of elves that
legolas comes from completely different
group of bells than the high elves that
we saw in linden but that's why you see
irandir's armor look like it's carved
out of the wood like that just because
each group of elves has their own unique
style to them
all of a render's talk here about the
past and evil being within them whether
they like it or not being still with
them is foreshadowing for sauron's sword
that theo finds like evil is literally
and metaphorically still with them also
you have all the orcs that are tunneling
beneath their villages trying to steal
them all three of these characters
though irandir bronwyn and theo are
brand new characters they created for
the show which is why i think they have
all these twists with the special sword
and with hal brand who's also not from
the books as well want to keep us
guessing about what's really going on
with sauron during the series because of
their relationship i kind of wondered if
theo might secretly be a rendeer's son
and they just kept it on the dl this
whole time but there's a couple
different things that could be going on
with the character he could actually be
hal bran's son or he himself could just
be like a young version of sauron who's
changed himself to look like that when
the sword looks like that i think the
whole idea with the restoration of the
sword the blood sauron symbol his
essence has something to do with sauron
returning in true form but right now i'm
still leaning towards the idea that it
might be how brand is the secret sauron
and once he gets the sword back and the
sword is restored then he'll achieve way
more power but not quite as much power
as when he's actually got the one ring
of power the whole idea with the orcs
trying to steal all these people i think
it's just the idea that evil is slowly
growing in this area because you also
have to imagine that even though sauron
hasn't gotten even close to creating the
rings of power yet over the many many
hundreds thousands of years there were
all kinds of different wards with orcs
along the way like lesser wars so there
will be big battles on the show that
don't have anything to do with sauron
himself yet the whole idea right now is
that sauron has been trying to hide out
for the last hundred years but i think
the whole idea with this sword the sigil
binding his power to the sword itself
and these other marks is sort of like
his prototype for working on the rings
of power in the way that the rings work
and when you look at the descriptions of
sauron during this period in the books
they say that he appeared to everyone as
a friend claiming to help them in
creating the rings of power hal brand
literally winds up saving galadriel's
life using the very dagger that she
wants to use to kill him eventually and
it was on her brother's body when he was
tortured and killed by sauron there's
this weird chemistry between the two of
them so it seems like she kind of hates
him right now but she'll eventually grow
to like him like something a little bit
spicy is going on here that just feels
like something that sauron would try to
do some trick he would try to pull the
whole idea is that it's supposed to be
the person you least expect like the
nicest person ever oh he could never be
sauron he just saved my life i'd be dead
if it weren't for him and when you
actually look at sauron's true form this
is actually deleted scene from return of
the king but this is what sauron looks
like in his original angelic form he's
supposed to be this really beautiful
looking angel so i think the whole idea
is that they wanted to cast an
attractive looking person as sauron and
someone you wouldn't suspect which is
also why they changed some of the book
plot behind what his name is and what he
makes himself look like so that all the
book readers won't just point and be
like oh it's the guy anatar right there
because that's his name in the books you
can all let me know in the comments
though like who do you think is sauron
after the first couple of episodes who
is he pretending to be remember he's
supposed to wash up looking like a
friend and he's also supposed to deceive
the new minorians leading them to
eventually invade valinor inviting the
destruction from a louvitar and in this
episode hal bran literally washes up on
numenor
also when the sea serpent is attacking
all their people hal brand is with those
others their
you'll ask them later how come you
didn't care about any of the people
you're with and he just talks about
surviving that also feels kind of like a
sauron thing to do like i don't really
care about any of those other people i
just want to survive myself but then
they obviously end the episode with the
meteor man crashing to earth i'll kind
of explain what i think is going on with
this character and how there's a
misdirect with the very eye of sauron
looking fire ring around him episode two
is titled adrift that's just a reference
to galadriel's adventure at sea with hal
brand being rescued by the numenoreans
they also debut the new intro scene it
starts with the shapes of the two trees
and basically like all the shifting
shapes here are meant to retell the
prologue story like the story of the
show in general the timeline that you
got during episode one that's why at the
end here it shifts into the shape of the
ring like the one ring of power because
the show is all about the creation of
the rings of power elrond goes to oregon
to meet keller brimbore and he tells him
about his plan to create the greatest
forge in the history of the world like i
said they'll probably use the force to
create the actual rings of power in the
myth role that the dwarves had found at
the end of the episode like the mithril
itself will be the substance they used
to shape into the actual rings we get a
really cool really quick history lesson
when elrond sees feyenoord's hammer
talking about the history of the
silmarils how he created them how they
led to the war of wrath what happened
with morgoth when keller brimbour says
true creation requires sacrifice that's
also a reference to sauron creating the
one ring of power because he pours so
much of himself literally and
metaphorically into the actual ring like
he poured his life force into the ring
which is also why you can't truly kill
him unless you destroy the ring
pretty much everything that comes out of
kell brimboard's mouth here is meant to
be foreshadowing for the creation of the
rings of power themselves how he feels
about his life's work creating something
of true power sauron in disguise
ultimately trying to use his own pride
against him then we get to see kaza doom
in its prime for the first time on the
show but remember by the time of the
movies in the third age the balrog had
already taken over this area the armies
the orcs had moved in killed all the
dwarves that had remained we did
actually see a version of the balrog
during the trailer so we'll see when it
actually shows up i don't know which
episode they're going to feature it in
but the whole thing with elrond invoking
the contest to gain the audience with
durin is just to sort of brush over a
lot of the history between the two of
them because as duran says he is super
pissed off at him for missing most of
his major life events because even
though dwarves do have longer lifespans
than normal humans it's still like the
blink of an eye to an elf his wife desa
here is a totally new character they've
created for the show i don't know how
big of a character she's gonna be
then when we jump back to galadriel and
hal brand she asked him about his
necklace like i said it's got the same
symbol on it of the village that bronwyn
and theo come from in the southlands so
i think that hal brand is connected to
sauron's sword which is one of the
reasons why i think that hal brand is
sauron in disguise because he's been so
helpful saving galadriel's life kind of
forming that bond between the two of
them so that when there's like a reveal
of him really being sauron in later
episodes potentially if it really is hal
brand it'll be this way bigger wtf
payoff because if galadriel starts to
have feelings for him wouldn't that be a
much bigger twist she actually finds
herself caring about the very person
that she's sworn her life to destroy it
could be a misdirect could be someone
else but right now just hal bran seems
like the strongest candidate you can
also let me know in the comments though
because of the connection to sauron's
sword here do you think that theo is
either hal brand's son or do you think
he's secretly a ron dear son but they
end episode 2 with them seemingly
rescued by what i think is going to wind
up being isildur during the prologue of
the fellowship of the ring the war of
the last alliance he's the prince of
gondor that winds up defeating sauron
and taking the one ring of power with
the shard of narcill but at this point
earlier in the timeline before the
destruction of numenor he and his father
are still living on numenor so we'll get
like the deep dive into numenor when we
visit the island in episode 3 next week
the way they depict numenor in the world
of lord of the rings is kind of like an
atlantis type of advanced culture
because they have extended lives like
they just have way better seafaring
technology just all of their technology
in general is way better but a silver is
basically like aragorn's great great
grandfather many times removed so lots
of connections to what happens during
the events of the lord of the rings
movies obviously a lot of history that
they cover in the silmarillion if
there's any really big easter eggs or
wtf moments during the episodes that i
didn't talk about during the video just
write them below in the comments or if
you have big questions about what's
going on with the characters there's so
much stuff that they cover in these
first couple of episodes you could do
like an entire hour-long video just
about the prologue itself because
there's just so much history that they
cover in such a short time span but my
full episode 3 video will post next week
there's going to be eight episodes total
like i said so make sure you enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss
that my full house of the dragon episode
3 video will post sunday too everyone
click here for my full house the dragon
episode 3 trailer video and click here
for my full house of the dragon episode
2 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys
in the next one
you